hey everyone welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation today
I've got one goal I want to explain how
it is that an Einstein's general theory
of relativity gravity cannot only be
attractive the version of gravity that
we all know and love we experience it
all the time but gravity can also be
repulsive it can also push outward and
to motivate this there in a number of
ways of motivating it but I think the
best way of motivating it is to use the
recent observations I guess it's not
that recent any longer I'm getting old
right but in 1998 there was the shocking
realization which I'll review in half a
second that not only is universe
expanding it's speeding up in its
expansion something must be pushing
everything apart so that is the the
motivation which I'll get to in half a
second but let's just set that in some
historical context right so we all know
and I've described in an earlier episode
let me bring this up on the screen here
good we all know that Albert Einstein
thought as many people did that the
universe on the largest of scales was
not changing eternal static always had
the form that we witnessed on the
largest of scales things do not change
and his perspective was changed by Edwin
Hubble who you see in the background
here
Einstein looking through the telescope
at I believe this must be Mount Wilson
Observatory I can't I can't swear that I
don't know what this photograph has
taken but I imagine that's where it was
so it's not that Einstein actually did
the observations but it's kind of a
beautiful encapsulation in this image of
Einstein's turn around right from
viewing the universe in his mind to
being static and unchanging to viewing
the universe as it actually is something
that is changing over time because what
Hubble had established is that the
distant galaxies are all rushing away
from us and the pattern of their
receding from us the speed of their
motion
being proportional to their distance the
farther away galaxy is the faster it's
moving away from us is exactly in
keeping with Einsteins own general
theory of relativity so if you want more
on that subject you can see it in an
earlier episode of your daily equation I
think was called the Big Bang and
Einstein I don't know something like
that you'll find it if you're interested
but anyway the bottom line is since 1929
we have known that space is expanding
the universe is stretching but everybody
more or less everybody there are a few
visionaries who thought that what I'm
about to tell you might not be the case
but just about everybody thought that
yes it's expanding but it must be
slowing down in its expansion slowing
down in the speed of recession of the
distant galaxies why well you know
something that we all know about you
know you toss something up in the air it
goes up slower and slower because
gravity pulls it back right so the
iconic example I'll show you what here
is an apple toss an apple upward it goes
up slower and slower because gravity
pulls it back similarly most everybody
thought that the speed of recession of
the galaxies would slow down because
every galaxy is pulling on every other
and so the attractive nature of gravity
seemed to ineluctably suggests that the
expansion of space should slow down over
time and people were so certain in that
it was slowing down decelerating if you
will that there was a parameter in
cosmological models called Q usually Q
was the deceleration parameter of the
universe and this is a measurable
quantity in principle for many decades
we didn't have the capacity to measure
it but starting in the 1990s we began to
have the ability to measure distant
galaxies by looking at supernova
explosions within
and that gives us a beacon that we can
see like clear across the cosmos so we
can look back in time in essence and see
how fast a distant galaxy was moving at
an earlier time and in principle that
allows us to make a plot of how the
speed of the recession has changed over
time looking at galaxies it for
distances different distances is
equivalent to looking at galaxies at
different times examining the expansion
history therefore of the universe so two
teams one led by Brian Schmidt who I've
spent some quality time with in
Australia as we've gone down there for
the world science vessel in Brisbane
each year also Saul Perlmutter who is a
great guy actually spent a very
interesting few days with him in Paris
some years ago at a conference so these
are wonderful people
they're wonderful scientists and they've
revolutionized our understanding of
cosmology because their teams took the
steps of measuring the deceleration
parameter and they found that the
universe is not decelerating at all
their data showed that is it is
accelerating so the picture then would
be instead of the galaxies slowing down
in the recession speed they are picking
up speed they're going faster and faster
over time and it's kind of pretty it's a
pretty visual all these visuals are a
little misleading at some level it's not
so much that like the galaxies are
rushing by us faster per se it's
actually that the separations between
each galaxies and every other would be
growing over time the speed therefore is
getting bigger it's accelerating but
anyway you get a the rough idea from
that image so the question is if the
attractive nature of gravity is why
everyone had the intuition that the
speed a precession would be slowing down
if it's not slowing down
then the attractive Nate
of gravity perhaps needs to be revisited
and in fact Einstein himself knew that
gravity could be not only attractive but
could also be repulsive and this is
embedded in on Stein's general theory of
relativity and to explain these modern
observations we need to leverage that
quality of gravity and Einstein's
formulation in order to explain this
observation so that's what I want to do
now is just show you very briefly how it
can be and I got a switch over it's just
bringing yes there it is my iPad okay
whoops sorry about that so what I want
to therefore in in a fairly brief
episode I hope is talk about I mean not
that I don't like spending a lot of time
with you guys but I'd like this episode
to be short and making it longer by
explaining why I want it to be sure it's
a bit of a paradox in there but the
reason I wanted to be short is I want
the point to be really sharp and not
diluted by all the details all right so
I'm gonna just get on with it so we're
talking about repulsive gravity gravity
and also accelerated accelerated
expansion I'm out of room so I will
compensate by making my letters
unnecessarily vertical alright repulsive
gravity and accelerated expansion all
right so let's just get in I want to
show you the the equation behind this
house ago so again so what does Einstein
tell us with the general theory of
relativity the basic idea that you've
seen many times I've discussed it in
previous episodes just to be sort of
complete the idea is that curvature and
the size of the universe or let's call
it space-time as a kind of shape four
dimensional shape three dimensions of
space one of time this is given by the
mass energy momentum and other stuff -
that will be very important to us
because
in the dot-dot-dot that i just write
down will also be pressure is this
camera kind of at a weird angle I'm
gonna just move this a little bit it's
kind of looks weird to me but it's
probably just my my bad I said but
anyway so so that's the basic idea
Einstein encapsulates this notion in his
famous field equations of general
relativity nu minus a half G mu nu R
equals 8 pi G over C to the fourth T mu
nu and in this equation the the key
ingredient is this guy well they're all
key but the fundamental one upon which
everything else depends is this fella
called the metric the metric on
space-time that allows you to measure
distance relationships between events
that take place in space-time and and
what therefore is the relationship
between this concept of distance
relations embodied in this guy called
the metric and the curvature and size
that I described in the version of the
equation in English the version that
allows us to perhaps to have a deeper
intuition of what's going on and and the
important point is that you are familiar
with a certain kind of metric from your
experience in everyday life encapsulated
perhaps in your class in geometry in
high school or maybe even before if you
were particularly precocious which said
you know if you are on the flat plane
and you go Delta X horizontally Delta Y
vertically and then you want to
calculate the distance between your
starting location and your ending
location we know how to do that
Pythagoras taught us is the square root
of Delta x squared plus Delta Y squared
I'm just gonna just write that as Delta
x squared plus Delta Y squared to avoid
having to write the square root but you
can put that in if you'd like now the
point is that if I now warp or curved
things like this
and now this is sort of delta x as a
sort of poor version of Irving but now
the distance between your starting point
and your ending location in general will
not just be Delta X square plus Delta Y
squared instead it will be some number
that I'm gonna call G X x times Delta X
squared plus some other number called G
Y Y times Delta Y squared and indeed
there can be cross terms in general but
all right as G X Y Delta X Delta Y plus
G Y X Delta Y times Delta X so that's
the new distance relation on a surface
in which it's been warped or curved and
just to get an intuition for this let me
just bring up one example over here
alright so there there's the Mona Lisa
on a nice flat canvas but now let's
distort the Mona Lisa Mona Lisa by
warping and curving the surface and look
you can bloat it out you can sink it
inward and the reason why the Mona
Lisa's familiar face looks distorted is
because the distance relationships on
the canvas are changed when you start
warping and curving the surface so the
idea is that distance relationships
between one location and other and in
her case between you know her nose and
that iconic smile or the distance
between her eyes and her hairline
whatever when you change those distance
relationships you warp the way she looks
you curve the surface on which she is
painted and therefore distance
relationships are the natural ingredient
to use when you're talking about
curvature now you may recall as a
footnote from earlier episodes that I
introduced this I give a connection that
allows you to move these tangent vectors
from location to location tangent
vectors were used as our they're the
failure of a tangent vector to come back
to its starting Direction on power
translation around a loop we use that as
a diagnostic for curvature you can say
where's the connection in this story and
for those who are following at a deep
level the metric can give rise to a very
particular connection at origin free
connection that's compatible with the
metric so that the lengths of vectors
don't change along parallel transport
and then you can go from this guy to
curvature as we motivated earlier I'm
skipping over those details because I
don't want to obscure things but for
those who want to connect up with
earlier episodes I simply emphasize that
bottom line is that we have this notion
that the metric is the thing that allows
it to talk about curvature through a
very specific formula that gets all of
these guys arm you knew the so-called
Ricci tensor as a function of the metric
are the scalar curvature as a function
of the metric and so forth we plug all
those in there generally derivatives of
the metric we plug them into the left
hand side of Einstein and on the right
hand side we have something that
captures the matter energy within space
we solve the equations we get the metric
that's Einstein's idea but now let's get
to the special case of relevance for
today it's a special case and the
special case is indeed the entire
universe if you will or at least the
part of the universe that in principle
we have access to and the idea in this
case is that all of these coefficients G
mu nu which can depend on time as well
as XY and Z the spatial and temporal
coordinates in the universe this can be
reduced so in this case for two
dimensions we had these four numbers in
principle you have 16 numbers as mu and
nu go from 1 and 2 for X Y Z and T but
if the universe is homogeneous and
isotropic looks the same in every
direction over large enough distances
and has the same basic properties
regardless of where you are sitting all
of this can be reduced to one
coefficient that we usually call a
that only depends on time it's called
the scale factor and what the scale
factor does is well it tells you how the
distance relationships between any two
points scales over time gets smaller or
larger over time so for instance if the
distance relationships got smaller
that's what would be happening two
distances in the universe if it got
larger it would be doing that so I hope
I can go back as I can so you know the
idea would be you have any two galaxies
you know here's you know galaxy number
one and you have galaxy number two over
here whatever I'm not a very good artist
as you can see which is why I never
bother to draw anything and if the scale
factor grows the separation between
those two galaxies would get larger over
time the misleading quality of what I
just did is the galaxies themselves seem
to get larger over time no they are held
together by their usual attractive
gravity that is able to withstand the
expansion of space so unless crazy
things happen in the far future they are
not getting bigger it's rather that the
galaxies themselves are just moving
apart given by the scale in a of T times
some initial separation that I'll call
the distance D naught okay so now we
want the equation for a of T think about
a of T roughly speaking as the size of
the universe as it's setting the scale
for the separation between objects what
is the differential equation that you
get if you follow this procedure and you
plug into Einstein now in an earlier
episode I showed you some of the
equations that you get now I'm going to
show you both of the equations I showed
you one that's all I needed in that
particular case but here are the
equations you get so you get an equation
it looks like da DT the derivative of a
with respect to T divided by a this
whole quantity squared and this guy is
equal to again because we're in a very
special situation we're assuming that
the mass density of the universe is
homogeneous it's 8 pi G over 3 minus K
see squared over a squared remember K
from an earlier episode we won't really
need it so much today can be 1 0 or
minus 1 corresponding to whether the
shape of the universe is the
three-dimensional version of a sphere
three dimensional version McLane three
dimensional version of the saddle the
constant negative curvature case that's
equation number one equation number two
has to do with the second derivative
give it a different color maybe hot pink
so that's D to a DT squared divided by a
and you may wonder why there's always an
A in the bottom it's because we're
talking about the fractional growth of
the universe that ratio is a useful way
of describing things but in any event
let's just look at the equation T to I
DT squared equals minus 4 pi G over 3
times Rho plus 3 P over C squared those
are the two equations and because we're
talking about the possibility of
accelerated expansion I want to talk
about the acceleration of the scale
factor acceleration comes from the
second derivative say if you're talking
about the acceleration of the motion of
a particle it's the second derivative of
its position respect to T squared now
I'm going to look at the second
derivative of the scale factor with
respect to T squared which of course is
right there in the second equation over
there now here is the punchline when
you're talking about energy density
which is what Rho is maybe I didn't even
say that and I should just really
emphasize that this guy over here is
energy density which you know if you're
talking about matter mass is the total
mass divided by the total volume this
fellow over here is the pressure now
that's that's perhaps a little
unexpected in Newton it's just mass that
comes into Newton's equation F equals G
m1 m2 over R squared from Einstein
equals MC squared you know energy and
mass are the same so you expect that
to play the role of mass and therefore
having to row in here is pretty
understandable but in hindsight in
general theory of relativity the right
hand side is this more complicated
gadget the stress energy tensor that has
not only energy in it not only mass in
it but actually momentum and flow and
also pressure that's unexpected that
pressure can't contribute and does
contribute to gravity now why is that
important for the story that I'm telling
you right now
well energy density Rho unless you're
doing some strange quantum mechanical
things like Kasmir energy which I'm not
going to focus on now that's always
greater than or equal to zero right the
mass is a positive number but what about
pressure
well pressure sure it can be positive
but pressure what almost my pressure
almost looks like my density so let me
fix that but pressure can also be
negative what is negative pressure mean
it means it's sucking inward it's got
tension inward I mean if you think about
rubber bands when you stretch them they
want to pull inward they don't push
outward the air in this room is pushing
outward it's slamming into the walls
right the air in a balloon is pushing
against the surface keeping the balloon
nice and and and pumped up whatever you
call an inflated balloon but rubber
bands or even the surface of the balloon
pulls inward right and that's negative
pressure and that's important because
look at the right-hand side of my
acceleration it could not my
acceleration but the acceleration
equation that I have right here the
right-hand side has this negative sign
over here which means that if it was
only dependent on Rho then D - a DT
squared would of course be negative if
it was just RORO is a positive number
and you've got a negative sign over
there but in this combination notice
that if we are in a situation where rho
plus 3
he over c-squared let me set C equal to
one which is usual units that we use
just so I don't have to worry about
let's put this as Rho plus three P if
this quantity turned out to be negative
then that negative sign together with
this negative sign here we deal a
positive number on the right hand side
let me not get rid of it there and
therefore d2 a DT squared would be
positive right would be positive that
means acceleration speeding up in its
expansion it's this version over here
that we expected because that's like
Newton the speed of recession should be
slowing down over time acceleration is
negative but as we see because of this P
and here's really the point because of
the P on the right hand side which can
be negative Rho plus three P itself can
be negative in principle and therefore
we can get a negative over here together
with this negative yields us a positive
giving us accelerated expansion and
that's really what we mean by repulsive
gravity repulsive gravity the whole
point then is that this fella that we
have over here because of the pressure
dependence can give rise to a negative
number for Rho plus three P which yields
with the minus sign in the acceleration
equation an accelerate expansion an
outward push over all the outward push
is not from the pressure the pressure is
pulling inward it's that that inward
pulling pressure sources and outward
pushing gravity that outwards pushing
gravity gives us d to DA squared is
greater than zero so one key example
that I'll come back to later on is
something called Einsteins cosmological
constant cosmological constant a number
that Einstein introduced in 1917 because
he wanted to try to stabilize the
universe give it a
fixed-size that wouldn't change over
time and to do that he needed some kind
of outward push to counteract the usual
inward pull of gravity so he finally
chose a value of the outward push to do
that and that numerical value is
encapsulated by this Greek letter lambda
because for lambda and I'll talk about
this next time you can show that the
pressure is equal to minus Rho and if
pressure is equal to minus Rho then it
is certainly the case that Rho plus 3 P
will indeed be negative because you've
got Rho plus 3 times minus Rho and
that's Rho minus 3 rows minus 2 Rho a
negative value if Rho is positive and
that indeed allows us to explain the
observations of the accelerated
expansion of the universe that Brian
Schmidt Saul Perlmutter and their two
teams found they won the Nobel Prize in
2011 for the observational discovery and
this version of repulsive gravity is the
best explanation that we have had then
and still today to explain those
surprising observations in a subsequent
episode I'll also describe how repulsive
gravity can you be used for another
solution to a different puzzle which is
what sparked the Big Bang what drove
space to expand rapidly in the early
universe and as I'll show maybe even in
the next episode repulsive gravity can
play the role the answer to that
question to the repulsive push may have
been the bang in the Big Bang as we will
see but anyway the point that I just
want to make today and of course it's a
longer episode that I anticipated what
else is new is that gravity can be
repulsive and it's a very simple
equation that I showed you just final
bring it up on the screen over here it's
this equation that we have the
acceleration equation for the scale
factor that's the minus sign here
together with the
possibility of having a negative value
for Rho plus three P over C squared
because pressure can be negative that
allows a positive right-hand side a
positive value of D to a DT squared a
positive acceleration of the scale
factor a of the universe all right
that's all I wanted to talk about today
until next time until the next episode
take care